hey guys i'm off the grid for august
probably sitting on the veranda with an
iced tea right now but in my fine state
of florida ron desantis is doing this
would they do that because you're not
going to be able to contend with the
audit so they're going to crush a lot of
people
by doing that and i think of all the
things that have come out of washington
that have been outrageous this has got
to be pretty close to the top and and i
think it was basically just a middle
finger to the american public that this
is what they think of you all these
problems we have to deal with and they
think the way is to do 87 000 irs agents
there's going to be more people in the
irs than like a lot of these other
agencies combined now
you know they're not putting very much
might down at the border i can tell you
that right now but they want to be able
to do it and unleash them on american
taxpayers and so so that's wrong uh
fortunately you know that's one of the
reasons we don't have an income taxes
because if you don't have an income tax
you don't you don't empower revenue
agents once you do that income tax that
gives them the ability to really go in
and potentially talk and it's going to
be targeted at people
that the government doesn't like
foreign